exactly
Dutch national team played tapping France for 4 months
at the Ek who would you be in the base
if you take the current form of the players
at target will probably stand for bridges again
he also kept the previous 4 games
and you are now injured
in the distribution I would go for a
k van Dijk and the light
with hartman on the left and dump frieze on the right
seems the most logical to me
just with 5 defenders
by going to play
and despite the great form of frankin
I don't think he's going to play
also for I choose the light above getruida
because I have its shape at all slowly
start to find
de Jong and Reinders have to be in midfield
actually start
after that I would play with simons at 10
or as a right winger
of which there are 2 spots left
the few days slowly 1 form again
and will probably just start
as a striker or as a left winger
and finally I would go for the current form
so see choose Robbie anyway
it may sound very strange
but right now
I think he is the best striker in the Netherlands
with this team in 1 good shape
we could get quite far
who would you choose because